so for this video i thought it would be
a fun idea to react to some people's
rankings of game of thrones as
characters because from what i saw from
some people's lists there's some pretty
wild opinions and i thought it would be
kind of fun to react to some of them so
starting out we can do ign the top 100
characters of game of thrones and okay
we can just skip down since i don't want
to look through these like will at
number one he's not even a character but
okay hot pie 84 how dare ign the god
himself
how dare they
robert baratheon at 34 they do not
appreciate this man the celestial being
himself would be shredding through the
author of this article if he found out
that he's at 34. the night king at 32
wait he's not even a character he's just
an evil force so how does the knight can
beat out so many characters like the
night king better than robert baratheon
and hold on robert baratheon worse than
gregor clegane he doesn't even like have
any lines okay
what kind of terrible take is that
oberyn all the way down to 28. to me
that's very surprising due to how much
of a fan favorite oberyn is but this is
this is really weird so far ramsay all
the way down at 25 ramsey is such a
great villain why would you put him so
low and elena 24 elena tyrell is such a
fun character and diana ricky plays her
does a magnificent job so this is
already starting out pretty bad for ign
marjorie tyrell number 20. uh personally
i'm not a major fan of marjory tyrell i
feel like her mother elena taro kind of
always outshined her and was the one
kind of behind the scenes while marjorie
was kind of just doing her work on like
joffrey and tommen but regardless though
marjorie is still a good character theon
pretty close to where i would put him
i'd probably put him at 21 so that's
fine sandor the hound foreign
let's read the description let's look
through the description really quickly
he is one of the most dangerous and
feared men in westeros but his character
arc is one of the most interesting the
hound's journey towards redemption is
one of the most compelling narratives of
this series
that's a very big compliment to be
pointing about 17 but all right so for
that description alone i'm kind of
confused as to why they put them that
low but okay let's move on
okay okay
what kind of dog [ __ ] take is this bran
stark over olenna ramsey the hound even
bobby b
this character the most boring character
in the show a kid who just gets pulled
around complains and bickers towards
everyone and doesn't even say thank you
to meera
is a top 16 character oh what kind of
terrible take is this ign every scene
the hound is in is entertaining as hell
but bran i'm over here falling asleep
foaming out my mouth okay let's let's
read the description why what's their
reasoning as to why bran is in the top
16 his magical abilities offer look into
the more fantastical elements of the
world but it that's kind of confusing
because david and dan utterly downplay
his powers so that doesn't make any
sense so right away i i don't agree with
that whatsoever i i'm just gonna assume
they stopped at season six and they
didn't update this but even then the
season six brand does not compete for
top 20 for me joffrey baratheon one of
the best ones in the show top 15 to me
is still a little low but at least he's
in the list some people just eat him out
of it peter baelish 14 fine brienne of
tarth at 13. now she has a great concept
but i don't think there's a lot of great
scenes that utilize her in a good way
like there's barely any good dialogue
scenes with the character and she spends
a lot of time traveling around then i
think she kind of peaks with jamie and
after that point i don't think she was
ever as entertaining or engaging and i
can see why some people will still put
it this high some people really love
davos since he's such like a wholesome
and like lighthearted character to me he
doesn't like outshine the like joffrey
baratheons and like the really rich and
complex characters sansa
along with davos and brienne
are all really divisive but some people
hate sansa some people absolutely adore
sansa and really were attached to her
storyline to me though she's very
passive through the first five seasons
and doesn't really do anything to affect
the story she's just kind of being like
thrown around by other characters and in
the later seasons she mostly like
becomes more independent but by that
point the writing just turns into crap
and she's always trusting littlefinger
for whatever reason so i was never able
to be that attached to sansa in
comparison to other characters caitlyn
stark at number 10 now that's very high
like don't get me wrong like she's a
good character she made it onto my list
beating out a lot of like other like
main characters and like great side
characters to me is kind of crazy
ferrous on nine is fine tywin at number
eight i feel like most people watching
my channel absolutely love taiwan and
would put them in like the top three or
even five at least ign is putting him in
the top ten i'll give them that edward
stark at number seven now that seems
very high considering that he's only in
one season in comparison to like tywin
has so much more going on for him it's
just a better character to me yeah
jamie's like a top five contender that's
fine same thing with arya cersei
john i'm assuming daenerys is about to
come up because we haven't seen her
oh yeah daenerys number two i wouldn't
put daenerys this high above like john
and cersei and everything and then
tyrion lannister at number one that's
pretty much a very popular opinion
because of how amazing tyrion is as a
character so not like a terrible list
but
it's like kind of like 50 for me there's
some very bad pics like putting bran at
16. a lot of these characters are like
at least better than bran but all right
let's move on let's look at the rap all
52 game of thrones main characters
ranked vizus
[Music]
[Laughter]
basically a stodgy moralistic southern
baptist minister i'm from alabama so i
was actually not pulling for him
[Laughter]
this is a very terrible start to the
list at least bran's down here but
had 50 almost
i was going to go through all this
ned at 45 whoa jeffrey at 44.
oh because i'm turning the tear up
honestly this is really bad
how is joffrey at 44 he's one of the
best villains in the show
this is branson i'm getting sick my eyes
are actually tearing up i'm like having
an allergic reaction to this dog [ __ ]
this pure vile
like tommen better than john joffrey
oh
why do people shaft robert baratheon so
much ramsay at 36 what
joffrey and ramsay somehow the most
horrific character feels bad catelyn cat
talissa
talissa over joffrey ramsey stannis and
catlin
what
gilly
at 30.
kelly better than joffrey oh i'm molding
my hairline is receding the hound no
why is the hound so low
at 27
gb at 26. this is terrible whoever wrote
this list needs to be discarded from any
community that has a mention of game of
thrones can i make a joke about
masturbating with your off hands what
tywin at twenty okay who ellaria sand
better than tywin oh boy oh boy this is
this is really oh this is just
triggering me i just need to speed run
through this list jon snow at 20
oh
better than jon snow and jamie they're
trolling
holder
tony hodor
great character apparently oh boy let's
captain okay this is his troll
turn all the way at 14 okay let's just
sande
oh my god
i qyburn top five
gray worm at number two
i need to get out of this list asap this
is this is terrible i don't know let's
just go to the looper oh
i see it
number 14 brand why are people obsessed
with brands i didn't expect this video
to be this crazy these lists are
atrocious this list came out in 2021
they could very well be considering the
later seasons of when bran was utterly
ruined let's look at their reasoning
this all sounds cool but to be honest
bran's story is a little boring but he's
in the top 14
what brandon becoming king is
questionable bran has interesting
moments but overall he's a bit of a dull
character what so why is he here why is
he why am i looking at this and then
cersei all the way at 13 peter at 12
that's kind of where i put peter so all
right sandor 11 that's fine caitlyn at
10 again people really like catelyn i
guess she's a lot more like than i
thought jamie at number nine i still
think he should be higher than that but
hey
theon number eight again divisive
daenerys
samwell over jamie and cersei now that's
kind of shocking to me considering that
his character arc is pretty generic and
his relationship with gilly is kind of
just bland he never was like a great
character in my mind like he's like fun
and like charismatic his relationship
with john is really good but top sex
worthy uh i can't really agree with that
and then bran at five over
so many other characters i can't agree
with drawn at four sansa pretty high
again people love or hater turn to
number two tywin better be at number one
i'm gonna be very upset right now
arya so tywin doesn't even make it onto
this list
they're saying bran the most dull
character in the show is
better than tywin okay i'm out here all
right
screen rant top 15 game of thrones
characters screen rants kind of popular
tormund at 15. that's kind of high i
wonder who he's knocking out of the list
to take the place sander at 14. at least
he made it i would put him higher but
that's all right sir jorah pretty high
for my standards samwell most of these
characters so far are pretty high to me
brienne at least they included joffrey
in the top ten i'll give them that oh
never mind i'm retracting why do people
love brands so much like this is a
screenshot of season eight so they must
be considering all the seasons he might
be the new king but unfortunately he's
far from the best character in game of
thrones literally everyone who has
brandon their list is ragging on him
they're saying that he's not a good
character but yet he's in here these
lists just feel fake what how how is
this a ranking of the best characters
when they're just [ __ ] on them are
they just including him because he's a
main character daenerys said eight i
think that's where i put her cersei
john
jamie everyone keeps putting sons on top
five i must just be in the minority arya
theon at number two i don't know if they
under like for half of the show was just
being like tortured and going through
the reek arc acting wise was really good
but character wise and arc wise wasn't
that entertaining because of how
repetitive it was but like season two
theon was great and that's really the
best he was in my opinion and then turn
at number one so again another list that
does not have taiwan lannister on it
where's my tywin lannister love but yeah
i think that was a good amount of lists
to go through and i'll end it here thank
you guys for watching and if this video
does well i'd be down to do more
reaction videos